try to be here at this is beautiful
Institute ok so today I'm going to speak
about some joint work with Mathias
arrabar who was a PhD student bomb and
at the moment he is actually a
postdoctoral fellow here at at another I
in the program an optimal transport
which is taking place at the moment ok
so um so as you may know optimal
Transport has been a very active field
of research in the last 15 years or so
and in particular it has been very
successful in analysis and geometry in
non-small settings so in metric measure
spaces with very little additional
structure so what I would like to
discuss today is how we can bring some
of the ideas in this in this field to
the setting of discrete spaces ok so
then so the starting point of my talk is
a beautiful result by rod McCain from 94
and what he found is a very nice
connection between two down on objects
so first of all they do well known the
Boltzmann Shannon entropy on the on
probability measures on RM and secondly
the two buzzer Stein metric from optimal
transport which is a distance on space
of probability measures defined in terms
of an optimal transport prop ok so
here's the definition of entropy which
is just the usual thing so if I have a
reference measure em on the spacex then
for a probability measure mu the entropy
is defined by usual formula so by the
integral prologue row DM where r rho
denotes the density of New York respect
to M so that's usual thing so what is
this this versus time metric so let me
briefly introduce that so it's defined
in terms of not small transport problem
which is as follows so let me explain
the problem with the cost function so so
what you do is you consider a metric
space a polish space and on the space
you consider 22 probability measures
you and you and you regard this
probability measure mu as the initial
distribution of some maths say save a
pile of sand and this other probability
measure new represents a target measure
and it describes the desired location of
your mass so it's your job to transport
the mass from its initial configuration
new to the second configuration you well
on this transport is not for free so
there's a cost associated to this and in
this example the coastal be the distance
squared so to transport master next away
you need to pay a price which is the
square of the distance now and then the
problem is to find the optimal solution
so to minimize the total cost okay so
mathematically you define it in the
following way so what you do is you
consider gamma which is a coupling of mu
and nu so just a probability measure in
the product space with with marginal mu
and nu and then you integrate the
distance square against this probability
measure gamma and you minimize overall
gamma so gamma eyes it's a transport
plan which describes to transport from
from you to you okay so this this
quantity is is the square of what is
called the master Stein metric and if
you want you can also define it in in
probabilistic terms so it's equal to the
following expression so you consider the
expectation of the squared distance
between two random variables X and Y
where X is supposed to have la mu and
why is supposed to have long you know so
that's the same same definition okay
well this this metric turns out they're
very nice properties so first of all it
is metric on the space of probability
measures which are called p2 so it's the
space of probability measures with
finite second moments and moreover this
this metric space of probability
measures inherits very nice various nice
properties from from the underlying
space so in particular if the space
the underlying space is a geodetic space
so that means that i can connect any two
points by by a curve of constant speed
well then the bathurst I'm space is also
a geodesic space so it so you can
connect any two points in your space by
a curve of constant speed so it means
that letter exists the curve say say you
was the property that that u of t minus
u of the S or I mean the distance
between UT and us is proportional to t
minus s but that's that's a constant
speed to your desig in a metric space so
the security metric notion well in
nothing the most the most places we we
encounter well maybe it all depends on
the field of course so I mean this work
ship isn't about discrete analysis so
discreet spaces are of course typical
space is very which are not you'd as it
so you say the view and you are in the
past so you have the product yeah so I
mean if you look look at this problem so
you can always find find one candidates
so one candidate for gamma would be the
product measure yeah but but usually
this is a very inefficient way to
transport a mass in the other extreme ok
so at the other extreme I come back to
it later on but but but you're not very
often if this this first measure is
sufficiently nice then the optimal
transport plan so this is measure gum on
the product space is actually supported
on the graph of a function and that
means that all the mass which is at some
point x is distributed to exactly one
point in your in your target space so
the mass doesn't split
exactly yeah exactly so in one dimension
you can easily solve this explicitly and
in higher dimensions so they say in RM
it's is already much less that's cute
okay right so this is a this is the
optimal transport problem and the two
buzzer Stein metric so here's the result
by McCann so what he showed is that if
you look at the entropy so on
probability measures on RM then the
entropy is always convex along geodesics
in this process time space so if i look
at the geodesic with respect to this
metric them and if i consider the
entropy along with geodesic then i get a
convex function ok so at first this
might not sound too surprising so of
course what is very easy to see is that
the entropy is always a contacts
functional just if you consider a linear
interpolation ok yeah so here I'm
implicitly probability the reference
measures just lebesgue measure so just
the classical boltzmann and for peace
well so so I I take two from probability
measures on RN and I look at the the
bussers time geodesic between them and I
look at the entropy the behavior of the
entropy longest tourism and so along
this connecting passages
okay okay so the entropy is always come
back some linear interpolation just
because the function X look ask X is a
convex function but this has nothing to
do with this result because these dude
ethics are actually very far from being
linear interpolation so let me briefly
explain what is to your ethics are so
how do i construct you that 60ml a
certified space okay so i take two nice
probability measures mu and nu and i
take an optimal coupling between them
yeah so an optimal measure on the
product space which is a minimizer in
this small transport problem okay so as
I mentioned before if if mu is actually
absolutely continuous with respect to
the back measure then it turns out that
this measure gamma is always supported
on the graph of a function so let's call
it function side and what you can do if
you have this function is you can
interpolate this function so I fix t + 0
1 and i define ciety to be the linear
interpolation between the identity map
and sign and in fact is met they've
mapping ciety i can define probability
measure on the underlying space to be
the image measure of this starting
measure mu under this mat anxiety okay
and this turns out to be the geodesic in
the buses time space between you and you
so maybe it's can demonstrate in a
picture ideas as follows so here suppose
have here some probability measure mu
and here's another probability measure
new then take point here then this point
is transported for instance to this
point here so there's this not T I mean
the map sigh which sense this point to
this point and similarly tiersen there's
a thing over here
so this slide represents the map inside
and what you can do is you can just
linear interpolate between this point
and this point so this is an
interpolation is an interpolation and
you define probability measures just by
by considering the collection of those
points so this is new this is new and
this is a new T so you get some some
curve through the space of measures
which is defined using its optimal
mapping science 20 still right because
there is an underlying object is also
heat signature is it yeah and there is a
distance into the venue to capsule you
can ask if I take any other measure
hopefully we will inspect it is well
yeah what should be the distance sergey
done this tip convex yeah so that is a
natural question but I come back to that
later okay so what about like to
emphasize here is that so this
interpolation is quite far from being
being linear and what you actually do is
you're heavily using the structure of
the underlying space and so you're
really using the underlying space in
this case just RM to interpolate between
these measures so for instance if you
have direct measure here in a direct
measure here then the interpolation in
the Masters tight space would be just a
geodesic well would it be direct mass
which is supported on the geodesic and
so I factor drachmas here na drachmas
here and the interpolation will be
interested to rack mast traveling from
one point to the other so why do you say
it's far familiar ok so linear
interpolation would be if you have for
instance if you have dragged masses then
the midpoint would be just one half
times the drachma this wise this one
often the other dark but the transport I
mean sir is moving in a constant rate on
each of the
gsx as you yeah exactly yeah yeah so so
you lose Eustace continued a section on
the blank space but not the linear
structure of the space of probability
measures ok so this is a this is a what
I just said it's a highly non linear
interpolation based on the geometry of
the underlying space ok so you may
wonder what does this result actually
tell you about about RM so so here's the
generalization and this is a
generalization to romanian manifolds so
in this setting the following result
holds so for romanian manifold m the
following a certain sorry balloons so
first is that the generalization of
mechanics theorem holds so mainly that
the entropy is convex along geodesics in
the massage time space and I actually
slightly generalized this notion so I
use the notion of Kappa comic city which
is just usual convexity involving an
additional correction term so that's the
first Commission and this turns out to
be equivalent to the fact that the rich
curvature on my manifold is bounded from
below by a conflict copper ok so this is
a remarkable results well cough is any
real number
okay so this is a this is a remarkable
result for instance because the second
condition which involves richie
curvature uses strongly there the
romanian structure of your pure
manifolds and so do Richie curvature is
a Romanian object but the first
condition is much more general also in
order to state it you only need to be
able to make sense of the entropy
furnish you need to have a reference
measure and you need to make sense of
the buzzer sign metric and for this you
need to have a distance on the on the
line space why is it good okay well
there are quite many many consequences
of this so for instance it's very useful
if you want to prove geometric and
functional inequalities so you can prove
box Olaf inequality directly from this
you can prove structural gap
concentration of measure things like
this that's right that's right of course
so Romania manifolds it is but this this
definition makes sense a much greater
generality so it allows you to go to too
much more general spaces exactly so so
that's going to stir this exactly so
that that's that's what I'm going to say
actually right here so this is allows
you to define the notion of which the
curvature in the setting of metric
measure spaces just by imposing this
condition of quebec city of the entropy
landmasses I geodesics so this is for if
for every mu 0 new or rights so for
every pair of probability measures
should exist geodesic in the master
stein space such that the entropy
satisfies this connect City inequality
the recently perhaps I'm sorry for you
this is there is some definitions of
torturing drops how consistent of these
or yes at the same thing that does not
be the topic of my lecture
right okay so that's that's a motivating
that your work on ground okay so this is
a definition which makes sense in metric
measure spaces and it has some some nice
properties so it applies to a white
class of spaces so not just two small
spaces but also due to some some sort of
singular limits of Romanian manifolds
for instance it has many consequences so
many geometric and functionally
qualities which are already mentioned
just before and it turns out to be
stable under notions of convergence of
metric measure spaces and that's very
useful to pass through the limit and
this will be very hard to do just by you
having the usual definition of Reggie
curvature exactly right ok so the
strongest applications so you actually
made you all of those are valid it kept
us strictly positive yeah but you get
some other results also for a negative
number okay so maybe let's let's go back
one slide and let me explain the
intuition behind these results in terms
of this bill cartoon so the idea is that
some so you consider here for instance
the sphere which is the space of
positive curvature and you take two
probability measures say one of them is
supported in this little green ball and
the other one is supporting to the other
green ball and what you do is you
consider interpolation between them in
the space of probability measures which
will be supported on to this red ball
and now because the space is positively
curved the geodesics in on the line
space they tend to diverge at first and
then they converge back together at the
end so that means that this this mass is
actually more spread out in the middle
than it is at the at the end points and
being more spread out means that you
have low entropy with this sign
convention
so that explains that you have this
comebacks profile fan for me is it you
have to check this condition amusingly
one that have for example uniform on
balls in this condition you said it has
to vote for all news yeah choice of
sports ok yeah you can you can
approximate so you can do things like
this but but but basically you have to
check for 40 or probability is all for
all for dance class of measures in some
sense ok so let's let's move on so this
is a verse in very general metric
measure spaces but well the topic of the
talk is what what will happen in this
Crede spaces okay so maybe the natural
thing in this audience would be to look
at two points pace so very trivial
situation in some sense but already
quite interesting I'm just to fix
notation let new Alpha be the
probability measure which has mass 1
minus off at 0 and mass alpha at 10 that
it's quite easy to compute explicitly
devices time a distance and what you
find is that the distance between new
alpha minus beta is proportional to the
square root of alpha minus beta so the
square root is basically because you're
considering two buses time metric as it
was this quadratic cost function and at
the end of the day you take the square
root ok now suppose that we have a
geodesic in the inner door 16 space of
probability measures so this is
something which we need in this
destination of not feel on each one okay
so what does it mean to be dude ethic it
means that i can write the distance
between two of those measures along this
curve and this distance will be
proportional to t minus s personal
policy but on your hands we just saw
that this distance can also be computed
by the formula above and this gives the
square root of alpha t minus alpha
okay but now if you look at the left and
the right hand side what you see is that
alpha is actually older continuous but
we've held our exponent 21 this cannot
happen so it means that this curve is
constant so in particular this little
argument shows that there are no w2
geodesics in the masses time-space of
probability measures and that's not a
coincidence because it's actually true
that these masters time space is the
geodesic space if and only if down the
line space itself is to desert well I
mean rescale dependence of course in how
you do it but well the problem is really
the square root behavior and you don't
get rid of it using lots of sciences
yeah so so so W one would be much better
in the sense because it will be just
proportional to alpha minus beta but in
the continuous case there are good
reasons why w2 isn't much nicer metric
and w1 and I what well first in some
vision oh okay yeah so for some purposes
w2s is nicer doesn't only one product
after this maybe w honest it's nice and
not how he behaved under
okay that's also one thing I'll speak
about okay so the moral of this of this
of this slide is that that this
definition of lots stoom and villainy
does not apply to discrete spaces
because well there's nothing to check
you don't have any two desks the edge
between two votives one edge okay yeah
so then turn it into neutral right yeah
so then you're basically back into the
setting of metric measure spaces so that
will be kind of covers but it's not
finished from theory but we would really
like a consider just discreet France ok
so in recent years there have been quite
a lot of works on the topic of
establishing a notion of of richie
curvature in discrete spaces so here's a
list of works which is certainly not
exhaustive so there's been been a nice
Theory bye bye jaan Olivier which has
also been found by by other people so
somewhere as you learn in particular and
this is based on on the w one metric so
it's based on on a contraction condition
with respect to w1 which can be traced
back to the work of the bushing there's
been another approach which is in the
spirit of lot Kolani store so this has
been developed by my bunch of carbon
storm and what I did is no they said
well Darnell geodesics maybe there are
some approximate geodesics so they relax
is none of you Jessica Beth and
considered sorts relax notion of
convexity along these geodesics and this
is works quite nicely in discrete spaces
well there is another line of research
which is based on based on back Henry
criterion which is some sort of
algebraic condition which which correct
Rice's curvature there's been a lot of
activity in this direction bye bye stl
and his collaborators and there's
another another possibility which is
based on on a discrete version of
displacement interpolation but I'm
discuss that in detail because you will
hear about it after the coffee break in
Prasad stock okay so what we would like
to do is we will try to find a notion of
curvature which is really in the spirit
of a floating on each storm and which
allows us to prove sharp functional
inequalities okay so so the question
which arises is well why is this it is
one such time to metric such a nice
metric so there are a couple of reasons
but one important reason is there is the
following results which has been very
very influential and it's due to jordan
kindle ira auto at the end of the 90s
and they found a new way to interpret
the heat equation so what they found is
that the heat flow is the gradient flow
of the enthalpy with respect to the
bussers time to metric ok so what does
is similar to stay lean in so in
particular what does it mean to be a
gradient flow in the metric space ok so
there are various ways to make sense of
such a notion but let me explain briefly
one of them so let's go back to the very
classical setting of RM and take a nice
function Phi which is smooth and convex
on RM then for a curve you in the space
RM the following are equivalent so first
of all it is a gradient flow so it
solves the gradient flow equation
meaning that you dot it was- gratified
view and this condition turns out to be
equivalent to a system of inequalities
which are called evolution variational
inequalities and they look like this so
there's the left hand side assess the
metric and ears the functional ok so
this there's been a very rich theory
recently on this topic in particular
developed by impose your GV inside of a
word now one remarkable thing about this
this the second condition is again that
if you look at it then you see the left
hand side there is only the metric and
at the right hand side is only only
functional so you are not using anything
of the smooth structure of RM and you
can take this as a definition of
gradient flow metric space okay and this
turns out to be a very fruitful notion
and in particular this allows us to
formulate this result by drunk in the
narrow auto so what they showed is that
if I have a solution to that to the
usual heat equation then these
involution variational inequalities
holes and these are just the same
equations as you see below in which they
replaced the the square distance here by
the square bathurst I metric and I
replace the functional on the right here
by the entropy okay so this is a well a
remarkable way to look at the heat
equation so in particular it implies the
mode very simple and then of course very
well known result of the entropy
decreases along the heat flow but it
actually tells you much more so it tells
you really that the the whole evolution
of the equation is really determined by
the entropy so the heat flow is really
the curve which tries to minimize the
entropy as rapidly as possible and this
is measured in some sense using the
massive time network is ok if it's not
convex then then this notion is not not
not a correct notion but are other ways
to make sense of gradient fill symmetric
spaces but let me just State this notion
problem
ok so this result has been very very
influential and there have been many
generalizations especially into all
kinds of more general spaces so so
Romania manifolds some infinite
dimensional spaces subramanian spaces
and at the end there has been a very
general result by impulsive GD in
Saturday's which showed that in very
general classes of metric measure spaces
this notion of gradient flow coincides
with the classical notion of gradient
flow based on the dearest energy ok so
the question what your eyes is now is
there a version of this result in
discrete setting ok so let me just fix
the notation which is very very standard
so my discrete setting is I consider a
finite set and on this finite set I have
a mark of colonel actually no Becky and
I assume that there exists an invariant
probability measure which is reversible
so which just means in this case that
these detailed balance condition schools
okay then of course there's a as a way
to speak about heat flows i can write a
discrete laplacian by as usual formula
and the heat semigroup is done just the
the the server group generated by this
discrete laplacian and this is just a
continuous time markov semigroup
associated with this Markov curl so
there's a natural in flow in this
setting ok there's also of course a
natural entropy so again to fix notation
so T of X will be the space of
probability densities so no negative
functions row which are probability
densities for perspective I and the
entropy is just relative entropy with
respect to pine ok
so again let's let's do this the simple
spin first let's go to the two-point
space so much space is 0-1 I take the
kernel for simple random look and I take
the invariant measure which is just a
uniform measure on a two-point space I
recall it new alpha is this convex
combination of the rock masses so then
the question becomes is true that the
heat flow on this two point space is the
gradient flow of the entropy with
respect to the buses diametric well
here's the answer will enter this
pointing and there's no and the reason
is that is Ross's time metrik doesn't
get very well in the discrete case so
there's this square root scaling and
because of that it's not not hard to
show that you cannot have any absolutely
continuous curves and it particularly
you can have any gradient flows
whatsoever of respect to this message ok
so if we if you have this result and we
don't like the answer then I'll just
change the question so it's time true
that the heat flows the gradient flow
with respect to another metric on the
space of probability measures on the
two-point space which is again 0 1 if
you like and now the answer is much
better so the answer turns out to yes so
here's a little proposition the lead
flow is the gradient flow of the entropy
with respect to some metric which is
known by this curly W and this is given
by this explicit formula which might not
be the first metric that you would come
up with in the set in a discrete set
maybe second all right if it is the
gradient of some metric
this unique okay so in this setting its
its unique but in more general setting
since there are probably many many other
options because you're basically fixes
the two-point spacing is noted to point
space yeah so basically you're just
somehow just prescribing the metric in
only one direction of your tangent space
then the direction where the gradient
flow is moving you have a lot of freedom
in other directions okay but because
it's one-dimensional you don't have any
additional freedom it is 2.6 okay so
question how can we generalize this to
general discrete setting okay so sorry
no I didn't ring about me but maybe some
other people i built but what was Arthur
canister the
okay so so you have this mysterious
function what's this oh it's a
functional all right it's a great house
for two are so this is a [ __ ] so I
let me draw the graphically social SEO
so you have this function between 0 and
1 and it looks something like this so
this is the integrins and what you do is
you're just the distance is obtained by
integrating or by this area it's
breaking between alpha and beta ok but I
don't expect you to see anything very
clear in this in this formula ok so um
so to get an idea how to to to do the
more general discrete setting let's go
back to the continuous case and it turns
out that there is a very nice
alternative way to look at the Masters
time metric so how does this work so
what you do is instead of just consider
the optimal transport problem between
two measures what you do is you look at
actually a curve in a space of measures
so you look at the trajectory so roti is
at independent probability measure and
if this curve is nice and smooth then I
can always write a dissociated
continuity equation where the size is an
appropriate vector fields so what's the
the interpretation of this equation so
here's a picture so you see here this
this curve in the space of probability
measures and if you regard this
probability measure has a cloud of
particles what you do is you follow the
trajectory of each of these particles
and you look at the velocity vector
field on this velocity vector field is
beside which is a precise lips I
appearing in this continuity equation
okay plus given such a curve row there
in general many choices of sight but
there is some uniqueness because for
every T you can find the unique gradient
vector fields such that is continually
equation holds ok and now there are some
some idea with Maxine it's strange at
first but it's gonna have to be very
useful
so this factor felt effector fields grad
site is now regarded as some sort of a
tangent vector on myspace of probability
measures so given a curve I can write it
in this form and for any DT role which
is a same in some sense a tangent vector
exists a unique gradient which I can put
here in the continuity equation so
because of this one-to-one
correspondence I might think about this
gradient as being some sort of a tangent
vector and now i can define an inner
product on on this on this tangent space
and this inner product is just the the
inner product control is just the way
they fell to inner products of these of
these gradients so waited for respect to
the venture rope so this might seem like
a very complicated way to to to define a
romanian distance but here's a nice
thing so let's now right the associated
the associated distance function to this
Romania metric so the so the distance
function is defined by the usual formula
so this is just a usual formula from
reminder geometry written in this
particular case so you're minimizing the
square of the length of a tangent vector
along curves and these curves i can
write in the form of continuity equation
with the right boundary conditions and
if you look at this this expression it
has a very natural interpretation so so
this quantity here so it's the squared
norm of my velocity vector fields x this
is mass so it is actually a kinetic
energy so the squared philosophy
integrated against the mass so what
you're looking at you're looking at a
minimization problem for the kinetic
energy and the remarkable thing which
was found by Buena moving venir was the
slit that this formula is actually an
equivalent way to describe the wazoo
Stein network so the last time to metric
is equal to this minimization problem in
the space of curves in the space of
probability matrix
so this this came from from fluid
mechanics this this kind of kind of
ideas okay now we have this this
representation and now the idea would be
in discrete case maybe we can can do
something based on this formula also in
the discrete setting so here is once
more the same formula and now in the
discrete setting let's try to generalize
this formula so here's the definition so
I'm going to define the metric in this
discrete setting just by copying the
things above and replacing them with
them if they're discrete analogs so step
by step so here's the interval time the
integral in space is replaced by a
discrete sum and the lebesgue measure is
replaced by this this sort of
conductance on the edge of my own my
graph s'okay was the qur'an i was the
invariant measure well the gradient is
it replaced by discrete gradient so this
is fine a difference well the next step
will be to insert his role so the
density then there's a problem so what's
the problem in the discrete case well
this role is a probability measure which
is defined on vertices of mine discrete
space my graph but on the other hand
this is the street gradient is defined
on edges so here I'm in the continuous
case i'm multiplying something this
gradient FX with this mass at the same
point x but in this great case it's not
not completely obvious what to do
because they're not if Roland brats I
are not defined on the same space so
it's not clear how to define this
product ok so here's a this turned out
to be the solution which comes out of
the blue I would say so the idea is you
you you consider some sort of an average
between the density at the point X and
density at upon mine so I define a
quantity bro heads of x and y to be this
sort of weighted average between Rho X
and roll why
and you can explicitly calculate this
integral and you find this this quotient
of discrete derivatives exactly exactly
yeah so I will come back later and
explain a bit how I kind of this this
object but you see it's some sort of a
funny way to take the average between
relaxant and Row one so we plug this in
instead of throw ex and we do the same
thing with the continuity equation so
basically we're replacing all the only
objects with their natural discrete
counterparts so there's discrete
gradient is a discrete divergence would
be some of our neighbors and this Row is
again replaced by this by this horrific
me okay so that's the definition of
metric deep it has a nice properties
this is again not just a metric but it
comes from a from a romanian structure
and it's this Romanian structure is very
much analogous to the continuous setting
so I can characterize the tangent space
in terms of discrete gradients and
here's here's a result which really
justifies this definition in some sense
so the discrete heat flow so just given
by this continuous time Markov chain is
the gradient flow of the entropy with
respect to this metric so that's what we
want so let me remark that this result
was found in the way that I stated it
wasn't my paper but very similar
independent works whereby by a group of
people at Georgia Tech sachajuan me and
zoo and also by Alexandra puking in
Berlin okay so so what might seem quite
mysterious is why I by the web we have
this funny lebryk mean let me try to
explain that by given giving a short
formal proof of those days of this jko
theorem so it goes as follows so
consider a curve road sigh which
satisfies this continuity
then what you do is you differentiate
you entropy along this curve so if you
do that because of the robot roll you
get a lot road or +1 that's the one
cancels and the chain rule gives you
this divergence okay then you integrate
by parts so you get a gradient of lock
row times this road and grab sign and
now if you go back to this definition of
this Romanian structure you see that
this quantity is exactly the inner
product in my tangent space at Rome so
it's the inner product of this grunts I
and the brother flock road and by the
definition of gradients this means that
can interpret leave the gradients in the
buses time-space as the gradient of one
pro think about this for two minutes
then you see that it's that's the case
on the other hand supposed to have a
solution to the equation then i can
write it as a solution to the continuity
equation so i can write dt role as the
divergence of the gradient of row and
then i can write retro as rho times from
sign provided that side is minus lava
flow and what does this mean well it
means that we have this continuity
equation with this log roll and in this
Romanian structure you can formulate
this by saying that the tangent vector
along the heat flow equals minus the
gradient of lock pro and if you combine
these two two things then you see that
the gradient of the end gradient flow of
the entropy gives you the heat equation
ok so this these little arguments can
actually also be used in the discrete
case if you replace gradients by
discrete gradients and so on but there's
one place which is very specific
specific for the continuous setting and
that's this last identity so what we
needed here is we wrote front row as Rho
times grants of what row which is the
chain rule and of course we don't have a
chain rule in a discrete case so what we
need is we need to have some sort of
substitute for a chain rule and that's
exactly why this is logarithmic mean
abuse because somehow this compensates
for a lack of a discrete chain rule so
just defined in order to satisfy this
formula so we can write the discrete
gradient of role as this logarithmic
mean times the discrete grades of la
chrome so it allows us to have the chain
rule for for exactly one formula yeah
yeah question them to the first step the
derivative of entropy routine yeah the
screen you can get the dress chiffon e
ft logon present so that would suggest
some protease i am from room yes yeah
for the for you so you get this locker
oh yeah so this is this is just any
curve so along any curve we compute the
derivative the entropy so we get asked
us to e to the T not blood no no so if
if this would be the heat equation then
this is crap cyber big props block row
and you would get this the thing which
you mentioned so you get the original
form of brat log problem crossroad
doesn't compare well
well in yeah so okay so in some sense so
so you okay so if you differentiate the
entropy along needful you get the
dearest life form of local and roll but
you want to interpret this as some
Romani intense right so you want to
enter this is something quadratic and
you want to write this as something
quadratic and log roll and this
logarithmic mean allows you to write it
as the logarithmic mean times the square
of the discrete way in the flock bro so
in some sense it allows you to write
something quadratic even in the discrete
case okay so let's now go back to 22
knots student villainy so now that we
have this metric which in some sense
takes over the role of the system metric
we can do a very naive thing so just
mimicking the definition by lot still
any storm so we say that a mark of
Colonel has lower bound on the Ricci
curvature by some constant Kappa if the
entropy is cut a convex on geodesics but
now we'll use the new metric instead of
T haces time to metric so here's a
cartoon which illustrates this this idea
so so here's discrete space with just
three points you consider a curve in the
space of measures so yeah so this this
grey area I supposed represents the
manifold of probability measures so this
gives you a curve in this in this space
and what you would like is that the
entropy is connection on this crew ok so
that's a nice definition so what can you
do with this so what we can do is we can
obtain functionally qualities so suppose
that we have a reversible Markov chain
and consider the following quantity
which is is a discrete analogue of the
official information so it's the thing
which which prasad was just mentioning
it's really the dearest left form of
grants row and on a dervish the form of
row and lock row so this is discrete
gradient of row and the discrete
gradient of lock road and this quantity
is actually obtained if you
differentiate the entropy along the
along the heat
okay so here's the results so what they
proved in the paper with mathias lr is
that if the rich chick arterial bounded
from below by a positive constant Kappa
then we obtain the modified locks open
up inequality when it gives you a lower
bound of the entropy in terms of this
Fisher information and there's a
constant which is exactly the constant
appearing here as know about in the
curvature okay so this notion has been
quite well studied in discrete settings
in particular in the work by Bob coffin
and take alli and why says useful
equality well this this results is
actually equivalent to the exponential
decay of the entropy on the heat flows
but that's just because this quantity is
the derivative of the entropy so it was
by from the argument you see that is
this exponential decay a straight wins
okay so in the in the in the classical
setting of your money manifolds this
result is due to bacteria Murray and
with the notion of curvature we reopen
the obtained this is just discreet
counterparties results okay so here's
another result which is a generalization
of result by or not a generalization but
an analog in a discrete case of a result
by Auto and villainy so what we can show
is that if we have a modified locks all
FN equality then we obtain what we call
modified underground equality which is
the following inequality which gives us
a bounce for the distance so this curly
W distance between row and the
stationary measure so that's just a
density one and its bounds in terms of
the entropy okay so this is inequality
has been also widely studied in
continuous settings if you replace this
metric by the usual Master Stein metric
so both width w1 w2 has been widely
studied and your these are intimately
related to the concentration of measure
okay but in the discrete case the
analogous inequality with width w2
actually never holds
even on a two-point spaces from the air
some remarks so if we ask is inequality
then we can obtain also also prank or
inequality I just a usual thing and we
also obtained a t1 transportation
inequality which is the same static on
equality but now we have a w one metric
so this inequality has been starts in
particular by by Bob of them and guts
okay maybe this is your next slide a how
do you prove the certain space has
rights provision that's as well I think
it's guys next like fair and just use
beer is not so interesting is it
can you deduce the original inequality
in a natural way to do space from
I mean the entropy of that square
so so so you mean to go from there to
point space to the coop or something or
you see oh IC IC will kill you can you
deduce
okay so so in the discrete case there
are there are various vs of Lok Sabha of
inequality which which would be
equivalent in the continuous case but
they are not equipment in a discrete
setting so and these connections between
various forms have also been studied by
book authentically for instance and this
is one form of lock so belief in
equality one of the weaker forms so this
is not okay so there are there are other
other versions of this of this locks /
life but there are not equivalent in
this quick cases kill you can use it use
so you get it did you see no no joint so
you cannot go from from this one tool
well maybe there are so many products
you can deduce but not that I'm aware of
that you can go to other forms of lok
sabha from the bloody
Richie oh no I see what you mean I'm
sorry okay get something fun I see it I
see no I don't think so I don't think so
we do it's very natural there is deceit
flow so when you take the derivative you
get the delicate modified yogi so it's
very natural to get notified of us away
yeah so sorry sighs I mean that for that
reason I think you just get the modified
which is very natural with your city
yeah so this is modified Lok Sabha up
any quality comes very easily from this
from this gradient flow structure all
right I don't think it's possible to get
any other or to get a stronger form is
that in a lot of cases the why we care
about much similarly
hypercube in context of boolean
functions because of Agriculture
activity by Wallace from but they also
know so you need a stronger form flock
so but I've to get to go to hyper cool
well there's some form of hacker conf
activity but is there any sort of
conclusion you can draw privileged 4lq
nor know so far as I know you need a
stronger stronger form of box over them
let's please correct me if I'm liku
bring the pool you can either use your
proof improve ok so maybe let me just
finish my talks by mentioning some
examples of prickly Brits in bounds ok
um so you're some results by milkha so
we did some independent work so it
proved that in the case of finite Markov
chains it's always possible to find some
constant that every for which to reach
the curvature is bounded from below by
these constants now then it might be
very negative and even in a setting of
finite Markov days this is a non-trivial
results because actually this manifolds
so there's Romania manifold of
probability measures becomes degenerates
at the boundary so this is non-trivial
so our results of a milk are in
one-dimensional situations so what we
showed is that certain expertise ations
of [ __ ] clunk equations behave well
with respect to this richie curvature so
in some sense you can obtain in the in
the limits so passing from discrete or
continuous you can obtain there because
people continue much results so here are
some some more results which were joined
with Matthias ever so this is a way to
go to product chain so it's at tanger
ization results which tells you that if
you have a bunch of markov chains and
you have a lower bound on the curvature
for each of them then you also obtain
automatically a lower bound on a rigid
curvature for a product and this is
lower bound for the product is obtained
by the minimum of the of the curvatures
of your in the funeral individual
components and you see here is a 1 over
n that is just because of the scaling
pepper we're using so it allows you to
obtain dimension independent bounce
and in particular real thin sharp bounds
for the discrete hypercube so we recover
using this richie curvature we recover
known functionally qualities like the
known modify flexibility inequality of
the cube and the park or inequality I
both with sharp constants okay I think a
lot of time so am thank you very much in
the definition you take a cannon can you
take transition does not some 21 you are
thinking about like you know to take the
line and you want what so measure to be
the measure always bear some days
something like them yeah yeah so you
need to you know can you do that or is
there any way to generalize bonus yeah
yeah so that's no problem at all so you
can so this normalization was just for
for convenience but you can just apply
this to any continuous time Markov chain
so even if you don't have exponential or
transition rates with with experimental
one so you can you can do with what
you're suggesting something from and
weave them was the same with almost the
same notation same statements
I have very small comment recently where
she suggested to massage
I think that's a good suggestion but
it's hard to change it's too late